Well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Hmm.
Has that rhythm.
It's kind of peaceful
at night, you know, you see
no,
you see that kind of piece.
Well I put the wrong song. Yeah,
I like it though. You know,
you see how that has that
been a good guy again,
guy at night, you know, you see,
I don't mean wrong is then
you're not a good song.
I was trying to play an instrumental
dude. Did you do your dad? Dude,
that's pressed the wrong button last time.
Yes.
Dad's
Gigi.
Very good. Awesome. Sky
Higgins. Thank you. Uh,
I was trying to play this song by John.
Read is called Barf. Stiffler is fat.
Yup. Hello. Thank you.
Thank you both guys.
John and guy a big week for the two of us.
Your man, uh, t bonds. I'm
going to friend man disco,
one of the big mommy areas. Huge
climbing market. Pretty crazy.
What happened?
Five shows sold out at COBB's.
So we add in the show
Thursday late 10 o'clock show.
It is already at the time of this
recording. Half Sole. Holy Moly.
So by the time you hear this,
if you're in man friend Desco and
you want to come to Cox Comedy Club,
and this might be your last
chance to, uh, to see me, um,
real quick,
I will tell you this.
Your boy is then going to Jude or titties.
Caroline's next week. Saturdays
sold out. So there's two Friday,
one Thursday,
then I got some suggestions for Raleigh.
Ropy good. Crawling me. I like that. Yeah.
North Carolina. Good knife comedy club.
November 4th and fifth. That's it.
No raw meat. Raw meat. That's
really good. Yeah. Thank you.
Then Lou, Louisville, Kentucky, now
Loserville and that came from a native,
they said Loserville.
Sure. Who? Louisville
of course. Duh. Why didn't we think
of that Louisville? I liked the,
we've added the Jew thing to ourselves.
It's definitely good for the career. Um,
so that was are at the laughing derby.
November 10 1112.
We added a fourth show at the
Trocadero theatre and fill her up.
Delphia November 18th and 19th on there.
And then west Fart beach,
smelly balls, beach, Florida.
That Palm Beach Improv December the
second and third genes this week.
You go nice Sunday, I think. Yeah,
I do use this Sunday in Indianapolis
at mortise comedy club. Yeah.
October 24 Cincinnati it go bananas
and then December 9th and 10th the
Washington DC improved. Improved.
Got To get better. You know?
That's the whole point. Um, oh,
listen to that Steve Rowe. Yep.
Also, if you're gunna use Amazon,
the holidays are common kitties.
They're coming fast. Yup.
Start to do your shopping using our
banner. That's real talk, right? That's,
that's real talk. That's a really good
answer right there. Your mom's house,
podcast.com. Go to the banner at the
bottom of the homepage. Click on it.
You're hooking it up for real. You mean
no matter what your, whatever you do,
this is good advice. You're
just staying on top of it. Well,
here's why are they shopping
sneaks up on you, man.
Do that shit now and don't travel
with packages. Oh, that's right.
You know why TSA is going to tear it up.
You think Tsa is going to respect your
nice gift wrapping that you did? Hell No.
They're going to unwrap it.
Ruined your stuff.
Have it sent an advanced ship it with
Amazon. That's real talk, right? Yeah,
sure. The tire life for the holidays.
Let's start the show ready. Oh wait. Okay.
Let's do it.
Russia had its own pussy riot moment.
Yes.
What do you think of Donald
Trump's pussy riot moment?
Well, uh, I don't know whether this
would, I English is not my mother tongue.
I don't know where they would is.
I would sound
decent.
Um,
there's so many bushes around
your presidential campaign
on both sides that they
prefer not to comment.
Oh my goodness.
I wasn't expecting that.
Don't bring it in one.
Loving to them.
Go to your mom's house,
Christina visits.
Okay.
My girlfriend Christiane
Amanpour girlfriend and my dad.
Is that possible? We need to be, my
joke was that I'm pause. My girlfriend.
You Love Christianne I'm a Mama,
Mama, Mama Mama part. I do. I do.
I think she's your older lady attraction.
She's your Freebie.
You know why I want to
have dinner with one,
not like pick her brain.
Just have, you know, yeah.
As I want to ask her questions
about and you know what?
I'd let you give her the d babe. It's
easier. You're free. That's my hall pass.
It's your hall pass. I'll take it.
She's Rad dude. She is red. Yeah.
Smart attracted her. You just, you just
told her that I'm allowed to fuck her.
That's what she did when she heard that.
You know what I like about her too
is that she's got old school teeth.
She's got his old world teeth.
Like she didn't,
she didn't Jack them up with veneers.
Boy Do we have a dental update?
Oh my God, there's so much to cover.
First of all, we have to tell people,
and this is all on me,
I got,
we get emails every day and messages
everyday about people asking for access to
old episodes and a long time ago,
I don't remember why,
but we put like a lock limit
for iTunes to I think the past,
the the most recent 100 and
really didn't think much of it.
We just go like, okay, that's what
it is. But every day people go,
how can I get other episodes? And I see
that so much that today I was like, Hey,
will you unlock? Just put no limit
on them. And you're like, okay,
sure dude, I don't know if you've
checked your feet, have not. Oh,
it's been like Holy Shit.
Why did I just get 150 episodes died?
The subscribers,
I want people to know that
the intentions were to say,
here you go. Yeah, I'm trying to,
we're trying to give them for
free for free and easy access.
Yeah. I didn't consider it. I thought it
was like a cool thing that you'd be like,
oh great,
I can sit anywhere.
Because it would show up in the
subscriber feeds like their,
so like their phones are full
pick and choose the ones you like.
But anyways, now once you
situate that, it's uh,
it's so that you can listen
to them at anytime. Yeah.
So the back catalog starts at episode 40.
The reason being,
the first 39 we did with the original
red band. Yeah. In his studio.
And then we moved the studio
to our own home. Yeah.
And so it started to
episode 40. So that's, but,
and then I don't know if they're
in chronological order on,
on the Lipson feed for some reason. I
don't know how to control that, but yeah.
I don't know either or not
chronologically ordered,
but they're all there now and
they're on our, uh, libsin page. Uh,
if you want to go, go just Google
your mom's house RSS. Yeah.
And it'll come up all the back
catalog anyways. It's, um,
that is so funny. Yeah.
Sorry guys. It's so annoying.
It's really annoying to you.
I'm sorry.
There's so many pushes around
your presidential campaign
on both sides that they
prefer not to comment.
Lick Kublai Khan.
I hate that woman. Yeah. She's
really aggressive. She's really,
really sad about this woman. Oh yeah,
them, I wasn't talking to you now.
That's positive. Grab 'em
by the Pussy. Oh yeah.
Grab 'em by the Pussy.
Or there's this Ding Dong floating around.
This woman who's like it, Donald
Trump, he forced himself on me.
I was a contestant for Miss Universe and
I liked it. Oh, I liked it. We seen her.
She's, no, she said bud there.
That does also have to exist. Yeah.
Because the reason that a guy in a power
thinks he can do that is because he's
done it a few times. Yeah. And a few
times it was reciprocated as like,
that's awesome. No pushback. So then they
go like, oh, just do that to everybody.
And that's usually from dump dummies.
Yeah. But I'm just saying maybe she does.
That might be the highlight of her life.
She,
she could be a star fucker who's like,
that was amazing. This is actually heard.
This is the girl from seeing it.
Oh yeah. It was a shocking thing.
And now there you go. Is that Christiana?
Um, important. Yeah. I love it.
This guy doesn't know exactly like he's
Rad. He's like, trying to say is like,
there's a lot of pussies everywhere.
It's Rad.
That is your dad was essential dumping.
I've heard him say sentences like that.
You realize the Russians think we're
just the ultimate, oh yeah. Sissy.
Nancy boys. Oh, you were so weak to that.
I think Obama is so weird to them.
You know what,
smiling and last month. Yeah.
Joy. Joyous. Smiling. Okay.
Money.
Yeah. For pussies. Yeah, that's true. Oh,
relatives would think you're a
dope if you smiled. Cause a reason,
another thing to point out before we go,
that was a burp in my throat because,
does that sound horrible? Yeah.
It was like one of those things. And
you're like the, the bubble bursts here.
I know.
I've had that happen.
I missed that.
If you're new to the show,
big announcements only happen.
Major announcements after chips
have been poured into a bowl. Right.
And we got that from the morning
radio shows that they usually play.
Bugles you know, like, I've never heard,
I've never heard it referred to as abuse.
I think a horn horn.
Yes.
Stupid. No, it's so dumb.
Fucking dumbest thing. So down.
So our version of the morning radio
show his chips in a bowl. Yeah. Uh,
chips in a bowl.
Cat's eating kibble.
I like the cat and this is a big
chips in a bowl announcement. Okay.
Okay. Are you ready? Jeans? I'm ready.
It's official. It's official. No teeth.
No entry.
My tour official tour for 2017 oh is
launched tickets go on sale this Friday.
Friday is October 21st here is
a current rundown real quick.
New Orleans, Atlanta, Clearwater,
Tallahassee, Milwaukee,
Madison, Minneapolis, Las
Vegas, Huntington, New York,
Montclair, New Jersey, Atlantic
city, Bethlehem, PA, Boston,
Jesus, Green Bay, Royal Oak, Chicargo,
Washington DC, Pittsburgh,
Pittsburgh, Pittsburgh, Burlington,
Vermont, San Jose, Seattle,
Portland Phallus, Houston.
Um, they are all going on sale
Friday. Some of these, uh,
cities I will not add shows.
Some of the venues are big and I'm just
trying to get them, but if they fill up,
they're gone. So I'm really excited.
I've never done a theater tour.
Most of these are our theaters. There's
only a couple clubs. Uh, and by the way,
I also wanted to do this during
the episode and explain this part.
I know I'm going to get hit up for
cities that aren't there and I'm there.
You're not being left out.
It's just not part of the initial
frame of marketing for the tour.
For instance, Denver, you
know, I love Denver. Um,
it's just not going to happen
in those first few months.
But Denver is definitely going to
happen in 2017, uh, things like that.
So I just wanted to point that out. Um,
and also still get the tweets though.
I know Joe Coming Hawaiian.
I'm definitely going to Hawaii.
A cone to there.
Are they all deaf or these are the hearing
impaired and there's always going to
be some international stuff.
So there's going to be Canadia um,
I'm working on a u UK thing and
working on mom's strail. Yeah.
So these are all things I'm trying
to do anyways. We'll move on,
but I wanted to tell everybody that's
a big, that's a big deal for me.
Big Announcement and a that's why you
got so many chips in your bowl jeans.
I thought you were going to announce
that you're lactose intolerant. My God,
I'm shrimp and tolerant. Can I, I think,
can I tell you what it might be? Hmm.
Cause didn't you eat some of my
cheese before? Yeah, the shrimps.
So maybe the,
the cheese was pushed out by the shrimp.
I got tested though. I actually
don't have a food allergy. Um,
I got negative on everything they said.
Maybe a food set sensitivity,
which is different. Okay. Um, and
I also have to push my colonoscopy.
We didn't turn that light on that
light. Oh, that's a problem, huh?
I'll turn it off. Is it plugged in?
Yeah. Oh, I dunno. It's Kinda important.
No anything. Just do it. Okay.
Don't pause. Keep talking, talking.
Oh, you'll do that and I'll do that. Oh,
here's my theory with you because we
both just had shrimp that I made at home.
Yeah. So I feel fine. And then
you shoot your brains out.
And I heard it through the bathroom
door. What's wrong booboo? Wow.
But then we had that
Starbucks, uh, protein plate.
But you don't think that's better?
That's better.
You don't think you're lactose at all?
I'm saying they tested me that for that.
And you're not? Yeah. Oh, now I
know I'm not fun. I don't like milk.
I hate no god. If I drank
milk, I'll feel sick.
But I don't actually have
that 23 and me shit that we did or
whatever the fuck that genetic thing was,
says that we are both
lactose dollar. I Dunno, man.
Here's why I'm not going on the 27th
because I have to fly to New York now. Oh,
look at that excuse after I'm doing Ron
Bennington. Unmask. If you're in New York,
it's free to go to the 27th I think so.
Is that,
do we know?
I don't know yet.
They made an announcement so I
know I can talk about it. Anyway,
the lactose thing, that's,
you know, genetic. Yeah.
Why are you shitting after shrimp? That's
a term sensitivity. That's so weird.
I don't know something's wrong. Why is
that dog barking so crazy. Retarded.
She's so fucking retarded. So
stupid. She got diarrhea again.
So our baby got sick for the first
time ever. I mean 10 months old.
Our baby got his first fever.
It was a fucking nightmare because
of course you were out of town,
so I deal with this all alone as usual,
and then the fucking dog gets diarrhea
on top of the kid being sick. I'm like,
God, I wanted to blow my brains out.
This new dog doesn't stop barking though.
It really makes me want to blow my brains
out and they continue to bark. Yeah.
And then you go and see what they're
looking at and there there's nothing.
It really makes sure she barks
it. Absolutely not. I know.
Like right now she's so fired up. What
could that be? The squirrel outside.
It could be someone.
It's, it's gonna. It's
gonna make me go get her.
The only other option is to
have her in the room with you.
Yeah.
To go get her. Okay. Keep talking. Oh, for
fuck sake. I have to vamp now. Yeah. Oh,
for crying out loud. So, okay, fine.
The kid was sick for the
first time in 10 months.
That's the
story.
This is our life at your mom's house.
I can't wait to get a new studio that's
separate from the house and the place
we're moving to. It's going to be
way different than this. Anyways,
I the kids sick. I'm in a fucking
lather. I don't know if you have babies,
but the first time your baby gets sick,
at least for me, put me in a full panic.
A full lather. I mean I was having
like severe anxiety attacks.
Fee's been shitting in my closet
this week. Hi. Um, so yeah,
I wake up at two in the morning and bitsy
has diarrhea. 4:00 AM she has diarrhea.
It was a nightmare.
I had to shove Imodium down her throat
because the vet told us we could and then
it stopped. But man, what
a fun week at Casa Segora.
Baby's sick dogs sick. Everybody's
sick except you and me. Thank God.
Now you got sick. You just shit.
What, what was she barking at?
She was just at the gate just barking
at it. At the gate from the kitchen.
The kitchen get,
where's the cluster?
I think she's in there,
but she was just barking at the gate
we need in the baby gate. Yeah. Yeah.
The dog just barks it. Nothing nonsense.
And she was really intensely barking yet.
I think it's her way of saying I
want to come up there with you.
She got her wish and then Fifo
has shit in my closet twice.
Two Times in the last 48
hours. Not Cool. Not Cool.
Because he's sending a very direct
message though my feet. What is it?
I love you still. I can't let you up
right now. I'm working. Okay. Come on.
Come sit in my lap.
So he knows that something's been up
in the house with the baby and he needs
attention. Look at this.
This is hilarious. Me.
Okay. FIFA. Roney okay. Pepper.
Tony. Okay. Can't alone.
So the new national
translation has come through.
If I sat on it.
My name
is [inaudible] needs a bit of a bitch.
[inaudible] [inaudible] money
cause I need your money.
You have to have me get on me first.
And last time I turned the sound
and of course for two sooner,
so I'm going to have a holiday.
Hamilton judge [inaudible] get
this fucking who? Autumn my life.
[inaudible] [inaudible] badges,
which we did it to the employee,
but after each other they
will have showed him a
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I'm so you do,
what are you going to be seen by you
last night? I couldn't sleep my mouse on.
Thanks.
You don't think when I'm older last year,
how much are your course or a my, they,
we talk to somebody.
She's due back,
so we got multiple people wrote in a,
I have my buddy slay Monae who uh,
translated from me on Instagram,
but you have this one? Yeah, in the
sheet here. I'll just read it from here.
It says, um, hello. Hi.
Hello. Hi. How are you?
I went and got that
picture is with that woman.
I just wanted to tell you this whore
that sells her body and is using heroin.
This crazy, miserable bitch that
wants to strive me to pieces.
She wants to destroy me.
This lady just wants to destroy me.
I just wanted to save her money.
I said,
I have a friend who is single here
and he can send it in just a week.
I went and got the pictures
and the passport and the
ID cards are ready whenever
you can.
I'll come and give you the money to
take this fucking whore out of my life.
Please saw them.
I please this low life for miserable.
Tell her you're paying for your actions.
You pour idiot.
So may tell her you're paying for your
actions. Anybody that does you any good,
you want to shred them to pieces. You do
this and you keep having to pay for it.
Mother fucker. Salamay dear, I'm so
sorry to bother you about these things.
I couldn't sleep last night
and my brain yesterday. Anyway,
I know you have your own things.
We all have our own.
They think we're just living in a castle
and all happy. Anyways, talk to you soon.
Talk to you soon. Bye. Wow, it's
Ali, uh, Shabani. Thank you.
Um, I wrote this, I go, man, this is
unbelievable to slay him. And he said,
of course she doesn't really complete
her thoughts there. So choppy.
What is most shocking is she
uses a really vulgar language,
especially for an older person.
And while the curse words
translate literally to whore
bitch the words in Farsi
or really vulgar, like
she says, cost cast,
which you guys caught onto
it. It was a bad word. It,
it literally translates to
pussy stretcher. Hey, k a whore.
I'm just curious who is ripping her off?
Last time was about real estate.
The time passport in pictures.
She is nuts. Interesting.
Yeah. Anyways, thank you guys for
the translations. Salah Amaze.
Pretty stoked that she's not
getting all of these voicemails.
I hope I want Sallie Mae to
get a bank of voicemails.
Like everybody just got our
downloaded episode, you know,
I want to sell him on his phone to get
them at once and she gets 40 fucking
voicemail and that's your really
gets to know her friend. You know,
I don't think it's her friend. I think
solo may is a family member. Yeah.
At this older woman or a
daughter or it's somebody.
It's a family. Yeah.
Hmm. Yeah. I Dunno man.
I'm, I'm upset. She called
my phone the other day,
the Persian lady and then didn't leave
a voicemail and I was so excited for the
voicemail. Yeah. Sometimes
she doesn't leave one.
Yeah, she doesn't. I know that
that was really rare though.
When you told me that she was calling,
I go, oh, is so excited. Yeah.
What are you looking at?
Me? Just what you sent.
I'm been trying to figure
out what the play, um,
because you said some great stuff.
Oh, I also wanted to point this out.
I was talking to you about this.
I did a Burt cast with Bert Bertrand,
yeah.
And Wilfred Burr. And we were, you know,
just regular podcast talking.
I told this story about this lady I
know a friend of mine knows works with
someone who blew the Wu Tang clan
and she's not happy about it now,
but at the time she voluntarily did it.
Anyways,
I tell the story and to summarize,
my friend works at a music venue and one
time when the Wu Tang clan came to play
there, a lady he was working with was
like, I'm going to get on that bus.
I'm going to like suck and fuck
some Wu Tang. She vault. She goes,
she announced it. I would love
to blow everybody in the Wu Tang.
And um, he was like, are you sure
you want to do that? You know?
And she goes, gosh, that's like a
perfect idea. And she was like, yeah,
I want to do it. And he goes, you know,
it's like, it's Kinda like that, um,
that's how he was being a protective
friend, but a woman's, yeah.
Killed Square, but a woman's
choice, you know, she, he
was, he was being supportive.
You're sure live right. You're
supposed to be a slide. So anyways,
she says yes.
She goes on the bus,
she's in there for a while, comes
back, and pretty soon thereafter,
you know, she's, uh, she's gets emotional.
And then she goes, you know, that
was pretty terrible. He's like, well,
what happened? She's like, you know,
I blew all of them. And, and uh,
and she, she said, and he goes like,
you know, they hurt you or you,
and she was like, no, it was just, they
were just so mean, you know? Oh yeah.
You think that the members of the Wu
Tang clan would be savages. That's weird.
I know. So anyways, she was,
she thought she was blowing,
I think she was going to blow Joe
to see or something, you know,
the grateful dead night.
Nice guys, hippie guys.
If she had blown the Tom Tang clan
totally different because I'm the type of
person that would be just like, thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. Of course,
that's my philosophy.
Of course you're talking about,
don't forget on the groundbreaking
first we'd hang out and through the 36
chambers, there's a sketch and
interstitial between songs that goes, uh,
you know, I'm a cut your eyelids off and
feed you nothing but sleeping pills. Uh,
I'll show your asshole close and keep
feeding you and feeding and feeding.
And that's between.
So guys that improvise that I imagined
when they're getting their dick suck can
also improvise some things, a couple
of lines here and there. You know,
I got your back,
but your best to watch your front
because it's the Niggas who front,
that'd be polling
stations. Wow. That's very,
very accurate and very, and that's also,
that's a Jesus album. That's like that.
That's great advice.
Now those guys,
like you pointed out,
also talk about blasting the whole head.
Fucking blown out on it. Yeah.
Right. So there's also nine of them.
I mean recipes,
uh,
14 nine's the original
number. So, you know,
sweet baby Jesus. I made a couple jokes
telling that story to Burt and Burger.
I told him, I was like, she was
probably like, Oh man, even you got,
and like I got a blow Kappa Donna too.
Like you know, it's like almost, you know,
caps not even original, but you know what
I mean, like the not as famous members.
Anyways,
that's the story.
She got really emotional
because they were real mean.
And then later on she was kind of,
I think the next day like, I dunno,
inconsolable, right to the point where
my friend asked like, do I need to call?
Like do I need to, I think I told
them too like that in the story,
but I need to call the
authorities implying it was
there a crime committed and
she was the one that said,
oh,
I volunteered for this.
But it was awful.
I could, if I could have told
her that before. Well anyways,
I think this is hilarious.
Okay.
And I laughed a lot telling the story
because it makes me laugh to think of how
mean they could have been like,
I imagine ghost face killer can
say some really fucked up shit.
I Bet Ray Quan was probably eating as
he was getting his dick sucked and then
like food felt like he was
probably eating. Yeah. Yeah.
Or like a McFlurry and then it fell on
her head and he was like dancing for you.
Like you eat dick juice,
no ice cream.
Ice Cream off of her forehead and
eats it still. Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
So shit like that. You know, let's
go sit right there. You know,
he probably suck my Dick. You don't
want me, you know? Well, like I said,
this isn't like, um, you
know, this isn't a Yani,
you're not blowing a full
band. No Man, they're,
they're known to be savage and sure.
I mean like even if I made that offer
to like modest mouse or something that's
going to be like, oh thanks for a second.
Our dicks, you know, they weren't, they,
I think they would be the 12 year
old
picture. That guy again, his
dick sucked. Right. So anyways,
this shit made me laugh. I tell a story.
This made it to the front page of Reddit.
My Buddy [inaudible] Greg pointed out to
me and then I was reading it and it has
the full variety, but some
people were like, sorry,
I don't think sexual assault is funny.
It's not a salt if it's consensual.
Of course it was consensual to the point.
And also it just shows you people
are always looking to, you know,
get their agenda out there.
That even in the story,
like I'm telling the story with notes now,
but when I told the story originally,
I told that with the details of this
person volunteering and making it clear
that it was consensual, but there's
still people saying like, no, no, no.
The only reason they're saying that
stuff is because of this Trump thing and
it's in the air and it's,
it's like a topic hot topic or whatever.
Yes, please. It's so
dumb. It is dumb stupid.
Let's say if you're stupid enough to want
to blow the Wu Tang clan in the first
place. I mean, of course it's
going to feel bad, sweetie. Yeah.
You think you think it absolutely
is going to feel bad? Yeah.
Cause there's like tape there and
there's no duck tape and the Lutein,
is that the, the last member duck tape.
That's the guy he hasn't gotten out yet.
Hurry drives cabs now. Anyways.
Um, just to make it clear,
there was not even,
there was such a clear point
made that this wasn't, um,
sexual assault, obviously. I know,
but I just feel like stupid. And Look,
I've known you for a million years.
You're the least sexual pro sexual
assault. Personally. God Love Planet.
I guarantee it wasn't intended that
way. Of course, look dumb. You know,
people get their panties in a bunch over
Trump and now they're transferring all
that energy to you. Yeah,
it's stupid. Anyways,
which band would you
blow? Hmm, good question.
That's a new game. I mean, first of all,
I would look for a band that has
less than nine members. I mean,
she went for a week, highest
amount of decks. Awesome.
Now that's a really interesting
point. Topic. You think about it.
Would you want nine different
guys to not in your mouth period.
No one sitting.
I think this was somebody too much come.
I think also that that this lady was
thinking about it was too much because
that's a really good point too.
I think she, it's too much.
Do you think she underestimated the,
the number of members in the band
and that's why it was such a bummer.
I think she may have been watching
honestly some videos and been like, oh,
this will be like, like look at, look at
all the fun people are having, you know,
that's the porno. Like, like
she's watching like, oh,
everyone's like the affection.
Yeah.
Like this is what a thrill
this is for everybody. Yeah.
And then you get in there and
you're playing with the big boys,
you're playing the major league ball and
then all of a sudden it's like some a
rapper sitting on your face.
Blake. My ass, my ass.
And,
and, and in all sincerity
as a woman, I don't,
I don't think I could think of a band.
I would least want to blow all the
movers up when you, first of all,
there's nine guys minimum
mine minimum. No. Yeah.
Yes.
And
it's not like it's not the peace
and love music party. It's,
it's, it's the Blue
Tang. It's pretty much,
I'm trying to think if
there's ever a modest mouse.
They'd be a good choice.
Maybe like a depressive band play
radio head. They be great to blow.
Maybe like a solo act,
folk singer and just a guy
in a guitar. Adele. Hello?
One singer sting. He's all
tantric though. He'd be like,
you're gonna blow me for 16 that's
where he's the, he's a master.
He does yoga. Did you know that
Mick Jagger or we talked about this,
didn't we on Joe Rogan
show that he does yoga too.
He's in such good shape. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. You want to blow up.
You don't want to blow the older
guys. That takes forever. Forget it.
Just to get the blood down there.
That's what I'm saying.
You want to blow the young buck,
the 20 the Biebers of the world.
What are the quick one of those guys?
The boy band one direction.
One direction. How many are in
that spit on those little dicks?
I think there are four.
But like they're going to come quick.
That's the whole point. You're
going to come to many guys and what?
You're going to touch their dicks and
as you grab him, you're going to go,
you know it's going to be fast.
I wouldn't want to blow
like a heavy metal,
like Metallica guys stink.
Right?
Dick smell bad on the balls would be,
that's the name. Now, some of those bands,
they started off as like the stinky dicks.
Right.
And then later on when they got signed,
they change it to Metallica, you know?
But they're their first band names.
Like I never wash my ass.
Got to be so nasty, so nasty
all the time. Yeah. Yeah.
But I wouldn't,
yeah,
I wouldn't blow a metal band and I
would not do a blue Tang for sure. Not,
not a good choice.
No.
That's an intense move to
start off doing that. You know,
for your first, is that
called a blow bang? Yeah.
And I mean like even for a group, you're
like a girl who was like, you know what,
I want to like more power to you.
But to start with the Wu Tang clan,
that's a really aggressive varsity move.
You want to start off slow.
Maybe you start with a solo
artist, you know, Wiz Khalifa.
Just go somebody who just,
he's alone, you know,
maybe him and a Dj would have been
a good one. Hmm. Hanson Hansen.
Yeah. Two teenage brothers,
Jonas brothers. And they were
brothers. One of them now.
So though, right? This isn't one of
them still perform or something back in,
who knows? But yeah, to be like, let
me start off with these nine dudes.
These nine hardcore rappers sing
about murder or rap about murder.
That's why he makes me laugh. It's
really funny. I think it's funny.
I agree with you a man. Anyways,
also, thank you. Many thanks.
Can I tell you that Charlotte,
North Carolina,
some of the most fun shows I have
all year, they don't know this,
but they helped me build about a new
10 minutes this weekend. Great. Um,
which was really,
really fun.
And also Carlos Valencia
was my opening act there.
Really great guy.
And um,
he's a Columbian.
I don't know if you know what I'm drinking
out of my own personalized main mommy
water container. I see that. Yeah.
It's embarrassing that you
have that. Um, it's good.
It's refreshing. Where's your
water? Smooth. Refreshing
drink. Where's your water?
It's not water. That is a sparkling
water essence drink called liquid.
No sodium,
no sugars by sailor water.
Do you know that Kevin Christie hates
those [inaudible] he said at the,
it sounds exciting and then you drink it
and it, it does taste like nothing. Well,
Kevin Christie, um, is,
is talking like a person who
eats and drinks what he wants.
And honestly,
if you had the choice of a
liquid or something with sugar,
you probably do want the sugar.
But when you cut sugar out of your life,
this is the best it can be. Or you're
40 and you can't have soda anymore. No,
that's what I'm saying, man. Yeah, you
can't do it. Yeah, I can't do it, man.
You shouldn't do it.
I can't do it.
So I a blue band, as you guys
know, he's still with us,
but he's not here.
He's doing,
he's building nests and
all these different trees
across the city and I asked
him to pull these for us. Jeans. Yeah. Um,
some great pss.
I love always loved Psa.
Some of these are really amazing.
I haven't seen them all.
I've only seen a couple, but I wanted
to show you how they from the 80s.
Those were my favorite ones. The
old ones are the best. The old ones,
you know why they don't pull any
punches. That's wow. Yeah. Did you stop?
Drop and roll also? I remember
just making an observation to our,
our youtube viewers.
You're still seeing the old board.
I ordered an actual another board.
That's why it hasn't been replaced because
people message me things I thought of.
You've got a new board. Oh, I did get
a new board and I got another board.
I got to send back the second
board. That's the story.
Okay. All right. Here we go.
Jeans.
[inaudible]
power
gets broken yesterday.
No.
So
a Frisbee has gone flying into some power
lines and then the little British boy
was like,
I kind of go in there and then the little
girls act dat, dat if fag. No
stock.
Yeah.
Kind of like a,
you realize how today's commercials,
even p essays are 15 seconds.
They've actually given a him screentime
of getting stuck to get into.
I'm fucking bored already. I know
it's so long. This is like in real,
he's like give me the wood to open up the
yeah,
why don't I have to watch this?
It said danger.
You missed it said danger.
Yeah.
Now he's running to get a spray.
Can I tell you the genius
is that the girl never
does the dumb thing. Yeah.
The girl's like hey you go do that
dummy dummy, you would do that.
And the guy's like okay
cause he's thinking about all
the pussy getting blown by
the Wu Tang.
Yeah.
Don't do it.
Dummy the first
today when you bro.
Yeah. Dead. Oh my God. That's that
PSA you'll die. Did he tell you?
I talk about this in my act, how they
had to like tell us cause we didn't,
we raised ourselves in the
80s. Sure. I talk about this.
How much these were great.
They're effective.
They scare the shit out of you as a kid.
He didn't do anything dumb
[inaudible] shit
to keep away from substation.
Lemme try to get toys back yourself.
Otherwise you may not live
to play with them again.
Fantastic. Right. But I'll tell you
what, you saw that as a kid. Yeah.
I bet you didn't fuck with them.
Power lines. No, no. Hell No. Wow,
that's great. Yeah.
Mcgruff the crime dog, uh,
that, I dunno, stop.
Drop and roll member they showed with the
manual was you got to beat that into a
kid's head. Obviously you gotta to
tell kids from the age of four, hey,
drugs are bad. Don't get set on fire.
Don't touch the fucking power lines.
They don't know. They don't. Yeah,
you got to give them extreme
examples that's running that kid.
But that's what sticks in the kid's brain
that you realize that that aired like
between like shows you were watching.
Right, of course. Thank you. I like, ah,
family times, whatever family size
is over. Of course. [inaudible]
and you're like,
can we watch the other show out?
Hello? Sorry. Is Rabies right?
We're just pushing in
on a sweet little dog.
How much is that
so far?
We're just seeing a sweet dog,
sweet dog music.
We'll have to pull the trigger.
Oh my
God. Oh my God. So they put a
gun to the dog's head and said,
please give us a pound or
I'll have to pull the trigger.
Meaning give us money or this
dog dies. Yeah. Holy Shit.
That's a fundraising tactic. I gotta
donate immediately. Yeah. A dog. Oh,
look at this dog.
Beautiful Dog.
And then all of a sudden a handgun comes
into frame pointed at the dog's face.
Yeah, of course. He's like, what
the fuck is that? And then they go,
please give us a power. Pull the
trigger. We'll have to pull the trigger.
That's brutal.
I'm traumatized,
man. God, all right. The Brits don't
fuck around. Are these all Brits?
Oh yeah. Right. Yeah. They do
things a little harsher. Yeah.
They don't fuck around.
Little bit more direct.
I remember there was a campaign about um,
like loose lips sink ships during the
war and just those like posters they tell
you like basically if you blab secrets,
you're murdering your countrymen. Sure.
That, well I know that the, you know,
they don't like stuff
like a have a nice day.
I've heard that a bunch of English people.
Yeah. They, they think that that's so,
um, condescending. Definitely Eastern
blockers don't like that shit. Oh, I know.
I know a certain person in your
life was not a fan of that at all.
My step mom hated.
Have a nice day.
Or how you doing phone Edith to my mother
really hated having nice. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. It's really funny to me
cause you know what, to me,
I never thought one way or the other
about it. Like I never said it.
It's not my partying way
of, you know, I don't,
it's not an expression I part with,
but it also never really registered.
But it's really funny to me to
think about it bothering somebody.
You know what infuriates me? Mm.
And this is totally irrational,
but good morning. Good
morning. I absolutely,
I don't know why I've made cause I'm
grumpy when I wake up. I fucking hate it.
Good morning. Oh fuck off. It's that stop.
You know we actually had um,
a drop. Do you remember Carla?
My name's Carla. 24. Seven.
Carla haven't good fucking day.
She said you have a good fucking night.
Yeah.
I don't know where that is.
My mother would say that to people.
You'll have that good fucking day.
How did you know that one?
Did you hear her say that? Um,
I think you told me that once and I
left for an entire day straight because
cause we were just talking about like
the wild shit. She would say. Yeah.
Cause your mom, the first time
I met your mom was that a lunch?
And she said the first thing she talked
about was a content Bloomingdale's.
Yeah. She said this fucking content
Bloomingdale's. And I was like, whoa.
And I just, I mean, I was ear
to ear smiles, but I was also
like, she just opened up
with, there was a context.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. She doesn't,
shouldn't build up to it. You know,
she reminds me of actually this
last voicemail from Persian lady.
Very similar to the email. The voicemails
I would receive like the conspiracies.
The so-and-so's out to fuck me. I got
to get this person back. Yeah. Super,
super normal stuff. Yeah.
You have a good [inaudible].
You'll have a nice fucking day.
No, she wrote that to me. Yeah,
she did my mother.
That's why I wrote it to you
in an in a letter in the mail.
This was how crazy. Now
that she's dead. Sorry.
So hard because it's outrageous. Can
I tell a story? Why are so of course,
so my parent, my mother remarried
to this nice. My Stepdad,
this nice Indian guy,
right?
They divorce and I decided to write my
former stepfather an email just to say,
you know, hey, I know things
went south with you and my mom.
I just want to say thanks for being
a cool step dad. For 17 years.
You were in my life and uh,
thanks for being you keep,
you could have been a Douche
bag and you weren't right.
She checked his emails,
found the email,
printed it out, and then on the
letter, the printed email wrote,
have a nice fucking day and
mailed it to me in the mail.
Like I caught you. I caught you.
Caught me being nice to the man.
That was my stepdad for 17 it was
not a normal reaction. Oh, really?
Know what part wasn't
normal of that has changed.
That's when she loves, it's
horrible. It's real crazy.
Oh yeah. Super Fun to be on the
receiving end of that from your own mom.
No,
you'll have,
this is burger king.
I'm sorry ma'am.
You can go in and say,
okay,
Miss Carla,
Miss Bitch,
but you would have a good fucking night.
My name is Carla all day
and I ain't ashamed of it.
Why would should be ashamed.
Whoo. That's some good stuff, man. Shit,
we kiss my pussy too. That
was that. Probably one of my
favorite major jobs. Yeah,
I know. There's so many.
Yeah, watch. I'll profanity old school.
Um, but it was kind of a
sip. You're lacroix. Oh,
why would you want that? Well, I like
to switch up. My water intakes varied.
There's suck my pussy.
Here we go. Thanks mom.
You can suck on that.
Uh,
no.
Oh Man.
Yeah,
there you go.
That's it. Good old classics.
Good stuff, man. Uh, yeah.
My mom was also very racist to your mom
was talking about this on the show yet.
I don't think you've talked about
on the show, but um, yeah, I heard,
I heard that at that
first, first, first lunch.
Like she didn't even do that. Like, let
me gauge how you feel about it. She just,
she just went for it to,
that lunch was really like,
it was very eye opening and interesting.
Interesting is a good way.
Isn't that crazy that you still married
me despite my dad the first time you
meet him
[inaudible]
drops some, some embalm. Yeah.
Back in the day he was not,
he didn't pull any punches. And then
your mom was a different level though.
Your Dad was just more like shooting the
shit. And I could tell that, you know,
he was like, he was old world just
like it's just a old school guy.
I was like, okay, I knew I knew
what I was getting with him.
Your mom was much more unpredictable.
What like you like you would know
because she is unpredictable, you know,
like that. Yeah. So, but I
did not know what was not.
I didn't know really
what was happening there.
But in a weird way I kind of understood,
I thought I understood your mother as
being this eccentric foreign person that
has like a kind of big bold personality.
My mom is kind of like that.
Especially sometimes I've seen people
meet my mother and not know what just
happened. Like I've
seen them be like, what?
And I have to kind of go like, oh,
this is what she meant by that.
And this is what she meant by
that. And No, no, no, no. That's,
that's how she is especially is to
somebody really American, you know,
like with two American parents and they
grew up in the suburbs and like the,
and they don't,
they don't meet foreigners.
So I kind of thought that
your mom was like, you know,
your mother is like a fun foreign mom,
kind of,
she may say a word and correctly or
it has an emotional reaction also.
She's also much more
expressive and animated.
There's also a thing that I related
to with your mother and mother's very
animated. So your mother, I saw her
as well. My mother does not curse.
So that part's, what was it really amusing
to me that you're like this fucking,
she was like, this can't at
Bloomingdale's. And I was like, whoa.
And then she was taught, she goes,
I thought they fucking bitch.
Fuck you announced it.
Like that is intense.
So really it's a real, real,
she was convinced it's, it's,
I'm so glad she's dead now. I can
talk about this stuff. But yeah,
she was always convinced that
someone's out to get her,
the woman at Bloomingdale's.
And one time, I never forget,
we went to a Sushi bar and the waitress,
excuse me,
sat us near the restroom and my mother
took that personally and she called her.
She goes, you're fucking gook bitch.
Don't fucking sit me next to the toilet.
You're fucking gook bitch. And I was like,
all right, we gotta go. Yeah, you got,
you can't, you can't even, and I
made her leave. I was so mortified.
We can't be served. It's
a lot, lot of that. Yeah.
And I remember someone
cut her off in traffic.
I remember one time when I
was a little little girl,
someone cut her off in traffic and the
woman gave a look to my mom. Some look.
My mom was like, oh, you're going
to fucking cry. Like she was.
She would a fight with people for
parking spaces. Like we weren't,
we were in a parking lot in San
Diego. Oh, you're gonna fucking cry.
Like she was so crazy.
And My mother was fighting for a spot
once in San Diego and part of the yelling
at people with Dean or,
no, this is before dean.
This is when I was just a
little girl and she would itch.
I remember they had like a fight
where the two of them were inching,
inching into the one parking
spot and my mother won that one.
And then later my Stepdad came in.
Yeah.
That was the, I got to
tell you this. Yeah.
I don't know if I ever tell you that
stuff first time I really felt like I wrap
my head around what you grew up with.
Right when you told me that
parking lot story where,
because a lot of times people speak,
you know,
hyperbole with like exaggerations
and, Oh, you know, my Stepdad,
he was a crazy guy.
Yeah. I don't even throw that word
around. Yeah. Loosely around me. Yeah.
Oh, you know, he was like, he talked a
lot of shit and you're like, yeah, okay.
Like I, he had a big
personalities, what you're saying,
but you told me a story.
You Go, yeah. You know, my,
my mom, I stubbed out, they there,
they were nuts. And I'm like, yeah.
And you go like, you know, in parking
lots, like he would talk, you know,
Talk Shit to people. Yeah. And I
go, yeah, okay. And you go one time,
this guy, like they fought over a parking
spot and I guess the other guy got it.
And so then my Stepdad stabbed his tires.
Okay. Yes. Not that. Not at that moment.
So what we did was later he goes,
oh,
there's Indian. Let's go for some
ice cream, pistachio ice cream.
And because we used to go to the rite aid,
they're now called rite aids, whatever.
Thrifty. And that was flavor. So
I didn't know I was a teenager.
I get in the car,
we'd go to the Thrifty's for
the ice cream. He goes, hold on,
I got to do something, gets
out of the car, stab, stab,
stab this guy's tires back in the car.
And we'd go, got, we got pistachio.
So that's really when I go
like, oh, as other level,
other levels.
I mean,
I can see a being someone's story
from, they were in college, right?
I was fucking nuts and go,
but this was a 40 something,
maybe 50 something year old man.
And there's a lot that was going on
and he pulled over the car and stabbed
someone is tired and then we went off
and got ice cream. Ice Cream. That's not,
it's so,
it's so outrageous.
That actually was one of the first
stories where I was like, oh, she's,
she really did grow up with some not
normal shit at all. Lunacy, lunacy.
And I also didn't want you to know the
extent of it cause I wanted to marry
normal. I'll tell you, I've thought about
that story for a minute. I was like,
what in the fuck? He used to fight
with people in movie theaters.
Um, somebody we talking in the theater
and he'd turn around and tell him shut up.
And one time one guy was like, you
shut up. And then he stood out.
You fucking shut up. You want to take it
outside. Like it was one of those things.
And then one time in the grocery store,
some kid was crying and my mother told
the kid to shut up and told me that
Stepdad came in. I was like,
they were, they were a good pair,
believe it or not does too. I think
they found each other. That was,
it was like fire and kerosene and the two
of them together. That's the other one.
I remember 10 years ago, you told me the
story. You're like, this kid was crying.
My mom told the kid to shut
up and then the mother, right,
wasn't the mom got upset, they weren't
Gilson horse. And the mom was like,
don't talk to my kid like that obviously.
And then escalated into
take to the parking lot.
I would lose my mind if somebody said that
to me. Of course. Yeah, of course. Yeah.
It's a lot, man. I talk
about it on that. See Bro,
because you know what I found though?
A lot of people have wacky
parents more than have,
oh my God, I don't know. I don't think
I'm in that much of a minority. Who knows?
It's embarrassing. I gotta be
it. Definitely relate to that.
But what I'm saying is all of them,
and you should know that that's not okay.
And that's not, I mean, that becomes
your example. If you're seeing,
if you're a parent is like, I'm
a stab, someone's tires out.
It's not a good thing to do so bad.
And I knew it was wrong then,
you know, even when I grew up
in it and you grew up in it,
you think that's the norm.
But I remember being like
10 years old and thinking,
surely I was adopted.
I swear to God,
I had the thought that one day someone's
going to knock on the door and tell
that I was actually of another family
and they're going to take me away.
I really knew at an early
age that I did not belong.
And it's taken years of therapy
to reprogram, like to, to um,
to unlearn the bad learning. Sure.
All that stuff. A lot of it, you know.
See the thing is you're lucky that you
don't see that as the way to be because
there's people that get raised
like that and then they go,
I'm going to go stab some
times. Absolutely. Cause it's
cause it's what, you know,
learned behavior. Yeah. That's
a thing. If that's all you,
but I knew and I was like,
this is not,
this doesn't feel good to me
because I knew that the people,
like I go to school and I
go to my friends' houses and
I knew that their parents
weren't the same way. Right. And
I knew that something was amiss.
Oh this is really kind of holding
it together here. Yeah. And it's,
it's not just the immigrant thing cause
that's one layer of difference in your
home,
but it was like,
oh somebody mentally ill and somebody is
a bit of a sociopath and that level of
a short fuse as a real short fuse.
Something else. Yeah. Yeah. Some special.
Yeah.
Wow.
Sunday there will be a book about this.
I'm sure there will be or something cause
my God and that's just the tip of the
iceberg. Yeah. That's a
crazy time. Anyway. Yeah.
That's the one I'm one I never
got to know is your stuff.
Probably never made her step father.
That's too bad. I think he's still around.
Yeah, there's still time.
Good. You want me to,
you want me to tell him where we
live by them over. See if, uh,
let's see if he would, maybe this is
something he would relate to here. Oh No.
Hi. We'll stop. Hello.
Close. My efficient is not on a card
that she stopped school tomorrow.
That we were still big alive
by any money until the flood.
The show
what the occasion?
Half of it. Christine's, my
mum always finds a good thing.
You might never come because was a
big hype thing. Darn about last night
we, everybody is sitting around the
breakfast table. It looks like, right.
Having a conversation that we can decipher
4% of jibberish and then the mother
walks away to another part of the kitchen
and it grabs the competencies of
big hats in don about us Nazi.
That's why I like younger brothers
and sisters. I stay in dorms.
What a beef stays outside.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
The screen goes to black
and it says hi.
Yay.
You keep quiet about gun crime. It's
like pulling the trigger yourself. Well,
I should say that right before that she
shot the youngest child in the head,
the kitchen table.
So what part of this was funny for you?
What do you mean? I haven't seen this. Oh,
okay. I haven't seen this. I was like,
I thought you'd selected this for no,
no, my God. No. She shot a
young child in the head at,
at breakfast.
Okay.
And then it says if you keep quiet
about gun crime site pulling the trigger
yourself through that.
And they're not really not fucking
around in the UK with these, this,
that's not even that old.
It's 2006 good God, great at,
I remember in the 90s if you bought
a pack of cigarettes, it was way,
but it wasn't like these bullshit
surgeon general warnings.
If there are pictures of like black
lungs and most of the world does that,
we're the only place it doesn't
do that best because this,
the tobacco lobby stronger. Yes. And we,
we don't do well with reality in
the United States. That's also true.
We live in a childish reality.
This is the play it safe. Oh,
this is another power lines.
How I remember this one. You do
kids
in the power line.
He's going to get the electric
heater that had been electrocuted
spot. You'd never knew about claims.
Fucking power lines like that.
Oh my God,
don't do it.
It just jumped.
Climbing pilots can kill.
Don't take a chance with electricity.
Oh
Dude. So far. By the way, the
gun one is by far the worst shit.
It was really terrible. Who's climbing? I
mean apparently it's a problem. I guess.
So Psa,
I'll make a deal with you.
If your kite gets stuck in a
power line. Eat Dog food. No,
I'll get you a new kite.
You don't have to climb up the power line.
I think everybody should tell their
kid that. Uh, by you two new kites.
Don't worry about it. Yeah,
let's tell Ellis that. Yeah.
If anything's ever been a power line,
you get more of them.
Never go get wrap our son in bubble wrap
and make sure he never gets sick again
and never hurts himself.
Ever put them in the basement
that we don't have train him up.
I don't know that that
created an alternate world.
It's totally safe that he
can just play in. No, I know.
It's what you want to do when you have
a little jeans. Uh, here's one for you.
Thanks.
Nice Lady.
They're just showing
that everyone can get vd
pregnant lady is bt? Sure. The butcher
clearly as Vt. That guy looks sick.
Yeah, totally. As a cloud. Not that lady.
She looks sweet. Scott
Flowers. She's got to smell it.
When you think so these guys
gave him and his kid had,
that old man has meetings.
Well God,
the baby is feeding no horse.
The horse has BD course.
If you're curious or confused or get
information or a pamphlet for BD,
that's the beauty of it.
Helps your doctor
from getting its tech sucked.
Yeah.
So baby deck side. Yeah man. The
babies don't get vd. Of course.
Stupid.
Okay.
It's commercial is a little,
the horse doesn't have BD either.
Does that lady riding it?
Does Doug. Doug. Doug. Huh?
Look at me busy as a bee.
Where did I get all this?
Oh Man.
I remember this.
This is good sleep and I don't need,
but I've got the cleanest
house on the street.
I like it.
These bugs all
meth.
Let's see. The thing is they
made it sound fun, right? It was.
It was like you can get a clean house.
Yeah. Your toilets will be scrubbed.
You'll be nice and
skinny. Actually, what he,
I think most people would probably go is
like, oh, I seen the dial it back. Right.
There's this lady just a too much math.
She just doesn't know how to start
it off. She's just cleaning. You Go.
I want to clean. I wouldn't,
yeah. I don't want it, but I mean,
I'll do it like I wouldn't clean
and get high. I do other things.
Yeah. Fun Things. Fun Things. Yeah.
See this cute little vile here.
It's crack rock cocaine.
The most addictive for you. Think it's
the glamour drug of the eighties well,
that's the point of this front.
That little reminder, hey,
can kill you if you've
got to die for something.
This sure as hell ain't yet.
It's not effective. That was
terrible. That was stupid.
Like that wasn't even cautionary.
No.
Who wants to listen to him about that and
he slid have flavor flave do that shit.
And they'll be like, oh
no, I love him. Pee Wee.
This is crack rock cocaine.
Okay.
It isn't glamorous or a cool hook.
Kids stuff.
It's the most addictive kind
of cocaine and it can kill you.
What's really bad is nobody
knows how much it takes.
So every time you use it, you
risk dying. It isn't worth it.
All right,
well that's about what number we saw
how we watched his new movie and we were
trying to guess his age.
Yeah. And he's like 70 yeah,
I thought he was 48 yeah,
we start 70
he's way older than we
thought. It's 50 no, no,
no, no, no. I got a double.
He must have been 31 at the height of his
fame. And that was what, 20 years ago?
So it was 50 he's 64 get out of here.
Yeah.
Yep.
Paul Rodriguez.
Rubinfeld Aka Paul Reubens.
Yeah, 64 man. But they computer generated.
I didn't know that. Well, they did some,
some computer stuff on it.
Oh, the latest. Yeah. [inaudible]
64 I don't care with that.
He still looks incredible.
A Mace. Yeah. What is,
can I read this email from a listener
about the dog shit food [inaudible] so
last week,
um,
I ate a little bit of dog food just to
see if my poo would smell as bad as dog
shit because someone wrote in
and asked us if we ate dog food.
What are shit smell like it. Anyway,
this guy writes in, Hey Hitler's.
I thought I'd try him in here and say
that most of the unique smell of dog shit
does not come from dog food,
but in fact comes from the dogs.
Anal scent glands door.
There are two of these on either side
of a dog's. How'd he say ass? Hell yeah.
They helped the dog markets territory.
No Shit.
The problem is that with modern dog
food made of cow brains and maggots.
Fuck, is that, oh no. Oh Shit.
I should grab this. Okay.
Right in the middle of an email.
Sorry. Sorry, I was in the middle. I
know, but I thought I, I had to get that.
Now, the problem is that modern dog
food made of cow brains and magnets,
there often isn't enough fiber in a dog's
diet to push all that smelly goop out
of their scent glands
and they become impacted.
This is what causes dogs drag
your ass is across the carpet.
If that doesn't work,
you might have to stick a finger in
there and squeeze all that doubt.
We don't do that.
We take our dog to the vet and they do
anal gland expression cause if he dad
could do it by the groomers, they don't
really get in there the way the vet does.
Just a little tip. If you guys
have dogs, take him to the vet.
Bitsy needs to have that done
once a month. Is it once a month?
Because she's like a pure bred Dum Dum.
Yeah.
And you know they're genetically
defective. Yeah. So That's interesting.
I didn't know that.
Their anal glands make it smell bad.
[inaudible] interesting. I didn't know
that either. Interesting. I didn't know.
Does that look familiar to you or no?
What's a photo of two bottles
of water post show in Portland.
You got a full bottle here,
basically a half bottle of water there.
That's after you.
That's after you perform.
The email says Tom. Christina put
on a great show in PDX last week.
I was front and center.
Yes,
she did have two bottles
of water with her.
Attaches a photo of what they
look like at the end of the show.
One completely full one, perhaps half
empty. Oh, and on the podcast this week,
she conveniently didn't mention that
she dropped the open one during the set
where she probably lost at
least four to five ounces.
So based on the visual evidence,
it looks like she your kid about
three ounces through a 90 minute set.
She was horse at the end.
You just can't help some people.
It's no wonder why you're
the true water champ.
Thank you for your thoughts. First of
all, Blake, thank you Blake. Blake,
how do I know those two waters are in
fact my waters? Those are your waters.
He had them tested for my saliva
to make it genetically, please,
clearly decoy water.
A lot of pussies in this argument
right now. It's just not happening.
That's Blake bullshit.
I've been getting reports about you,
your lack of hydration in South Carolina.
Yeah.
I wasn't in South Carolina, North
Carolina. I was not lacking.
I was so hydrated. I don't, I didn't,
I heard lots of reports that you
didn't take any sips during your show.
He didn't bring any water up on stage.
Things of that nature. Yeah. Yeah. Well,
I did drink a lot there.
People were talking about it.
Nobody's talking about your hydration.
There was on the news.
Um, hello. Mommies can't help but
notice that over the past few months,
Tom has continuously postpone,
is required. Colonoscopy,
how we just addressed this,
but we did a few episodes back.
I was a static to discover
the Tom rescheduled the date,
the same as my birthday on
the 27th I thought, wow.
Tom's colon and health is
one of my best birthday.
A birthday presents a guy could
receive however I am now distraught.
Find out he was going to
postpone again. Beg of you, Tom,
please give me yourself and
your, your gift, your family.
The gift of a perfect colon health on
the 21st birthday on my 21st birthday of
October 27th I'll drink one for you.
It doesn't say who that's from.
Um,
but thank you and I will,
I will not do it on the 27th
because I will not be here,
but I will reschedule it again.
Why are you showing me?
I made you read that because I want to
shame you into making that appointment.
You just had violent diarrhea.
That's true. And I care about you.
Dumb dumb. Can I read this
email? Yeah. I love this. Hi.
Zim Genes and surge jeans.
I wanted to trim it on the shower debate.
That isn't really a debate, Thomas.
Correct.
Uh,
that for showers that are shower slash
Tub combos with shower curtains as
opposed to shower doors,
you enter from the rear.
Also glad that Christina quickly
realized how it was. She did
the opposite for so many years.
However,
I wanted to quickly point out that in
most bathrooms with this type of shower
tub deal,
the toilet is parallel to the tub on
the same bathroom wall as a showerhead.
Meaning that in order to enter the shower
at via the wrong slash psychotic way,
you would actually have to shimmy between
the tub and the toilet in order to
enter that way.
Just think to all your many experiences
and hotel bathrooms to know what I'm
talking about.
But the average bathroom is literally set
up to naturally allow you to enter the
shower from the rear stop fighting the
natural architecture of the bathroom
floor pan plan. This madness
must end love the pod. Huge Fan.
Thanks Rick.
So they're saying that you're entering
incorrectly doing that are our old
bathroom. The toilet was directly
parallel to the shower. Right?
So I would get off the toilet and then
squeeze my way in between the toilet and
the shower because it was
so small and our old place.
Of course then I would force the
issue to do it. And you such a dummy.
Oh, you're not a dummy, but I think
you understand that there's a better,
there's a better way.
Yeah. I really made an effort
to, to do it that way. So funny.
That seemed more intuitive to me.
Nothing back. And now,
you know. No, I know. Um,
don't worry this, this is too long.
This dental update, sorry. Okay.
In retrospect is too long. Well, I thought
we could play the other thing please.
Um,
let me see.
You posted right on the cheat sheet
first lane.
Oh yeah.
We're still, by the way, you lowered
the seat. No, I didn't. Yeah, it is.
It's definitely, I didn't lower it. Not
Manually. It must be lowering over time.
Really.
I didn't do it myself.
Like I didn't do it intentionally,
so I'm trying to,
okay. There you go. Oh my
gosh. Yeah. We need new chairs
so our teeth are still not,
that's embarrassing that we do this.
It's just too much going on after we
move. We need to find new dentists. Yeah,
it's been months. Uh, but it's time to,
to show people.
This is one of your greatest discoveries.
Was this sent in or do you
10 sentence less credible.
Incredible discovery. I'm really
stoked about this one. Yeah. Let's, uh,
let's see.
It's my be the favorite thing
I've seen in a long time.
Yeah.
Are you embarrassed about your
broken crooked and teeth? Do you
hide your smile because you're
ashamed of unsightly gaps and cracks?
Would you like to have
big smile confidence,
but just can't afford the expensive work?
Introducing million dollar
smile by perfect smile.
The amazing removable reusable veneer
that instantly gives you the look of
perfect teeth.
You'll be proud to smile about million
dollar smile fits right over your
existing teeth so you can always put
best face forward.
The secret is the super comfortable Mike
growth in polypropylene veneer Sibley's
soak it in hot water.
Press it on your top layer of teeth and
it custom conforms right over your teeth.
Instantly.
You can show off $1 million smile.
It kind of looks like you
got an a on a $10 million.
Yeah, the $10 smile over the phone. Uh,
what's it called? Made to order.
Done. Look at shopping TV.
That looks better actually. That site.
Yeah, and the gums rec extra red.
If you'll notice they're reading,
you're looking,
obviously they're not going to
match your bottoms to, well, no.
Kind of look like Rudy Giuliani.
Yeah,
these are the Rudy's hair.
He's a Giuliani's. You need.
That guy's a multimillionaire. He has
now, no excuse. He's wearing what? He's,
he's got his million dollar smiling.
Maybe that's what he's doing. Yeah.
Maybe that's what he's doing.
He a boy.
No boy. They are like, how does that work?
Cause they everyone's million
dollar smile looks identical. Yeah.
It's not custom made because everybody's,
and that's a gap.
That's not a knocked out too.
They had the same problem.
So then how does that makes no
sense man. Well, keep playing it.
Well, I know, but I just
wanted to show no, Rudy,
that's not looking at, and you know
are smaller. Right? Look at the top.
We've got the million dollar smile on top
and then the eight dial.
A dollar smile on the bottom. Yeah,
the Julian, what's his name? Fellows.
Downton Abbey smiles is, no, no, no. Ah,
Jesus Christ.
All right.
A million dollar smile.
One to
show off your million dollar smile.
See everybody who puts
in those flippers, they,
they don't smile normal. They
go, yeah, they get fairly open.
They're like barely show them.
They,
they look real clunky too.
Oof.
Dollar smile. Easily. Most
for job interviews. We're done
and that guy went, hm hm hm. Oh,
these are going to look great.
They look great.
Go on dates when you need to look great
and when the camera comes out. Okay.
Crazy moms look as too crazy, man. That's
a good friend of mine, mother. Actually,
she's really crazy.
Hmm.
You'll be proud to say cheese
with a bright white smile. Oh yes.
For dental coverage. This gives me $1
million smile. Oh wait, I'm in love.
Everyone's like, oh, here for
death cover. I know the nine laws.
My mind, you can't talk with
the million dollar smile. Oh,
I got the million dollar smile.
My new smile. See my smile. I look great
when I go out on a date. Nobody can talk.
I'm going out when I'm hanging out.
It's just fun to smile again. Big Smile.
Catherine. Million while
fishing. Big Smile. Confidence.
Nobody can talk.
Is a custom fit guaranteed or your money?
Look at her bunny size teeth.
Every fifth is a custom fit guaranteed
or your money back instantly.
You can have the look and
here's like good teeth.
Just snap them on in the
morning with a smile. Oh my God.
Can't afford terrible.
And this is a great, yeah,
no. Listen, listen,
I don't want to hear about how you
can't afford cosmetic dentistry.
I want to hear about you
have debt because you went,
you had cosmetic dentistry. That's
the right answer. Yeah, I have that.
But I fixed my teeth. Yes.
Just like I fixed my hair. Yes.
And I fixed my eyes and I fixed my face.
Anything on your body is a priority.
Things that people see with their
eyes when they look at, you know,
I would venture to say anything on
your body that needs addressing.
That's a priority. Yeah, but mouth is
a big in your life. You can't come on,
look at her. Look at
her. Look at this Dennis.
Cause you look like a dentist.
No, he looks like he's dying.
He looks like he backs up the,
the forklift that drops off the
million dollar smile pallets. You know,
definitely.
He's,
I got a bunch of million dollars
files on the back of this truck.
Fred van Curran. See his teeth actually
look fine. He doesn't need 2 million.
He's already got $1 million
smile. Yeah, he has minor.
Well they did is they show you the
three levels. His, his real minor. Oh,
she's got it. Yeah. And then she's like,
I don't even have any fucking teeth. See,
for her that's an okay investment. But
for him, all you need is some bonding.
What did this lady do
here on top to get those?
She didn't go to the dentist for
like 20 years now or worse than that.
Now you got the million dollar smile.
We still don't know how much the
million dollar smile is. Is it? Oh,
let's find out $100,000 is it?
What are you guys, wait, wait,
I don't know how much it,
yeah, let's guys, well there
I think they were showing,
they were trying to show an extreme at
the beginning and the head multi-tiered
prices of cosmetic work done.
So it's gotta be just infinitely less.
I'm going with $40.
Yeah,
I'm going to go with three easy payments
of 1999 so that's 60 bucks basically.
Okay. So, and they're trying to tell you,
do that for your mouth.
Do that in replacement of teeth.
Spend 40 or $60. No, man,
you make it happen. You make
it happen. You go to, yeah,
you go to a dental college,
go to the Philippines, they
have teeth. Go get it there.
Get a boat and sail over
there. Yeah, take out,
take out credit from the
borrow against your house.
You sell whatever it is you got to do.
And don't forget the cash thing I taught,
a buddy of mine did this
with a pregnant wife.
He let his health insurance lapse,
horrible.
Finds out his wife's pregnant with twins.
Guy has no car. He's in a full panic.
He goes to these different doctors with
cash and it goes, I don't have insurance,
but if I pay you cash, right, will you do
x, Y, and z? And they all said yes. Yeah,
he paid a fraction,
but he offered cash.
Can I say two dental insurances we've
discussed is horse shit anyways.
Oh fuck down. Just go fucking go. Do it.
Just go do it. Look, if
you're like, dude, I'm broke.
And I understand that we're speaking from
a very ablest ablest. Yes, thank you.
But I always like when I
was a broke ass opening act.
Yeah, still had dental work
done. Put it off all the time.
You don't want to say, I know what he's
done and we paid for it newly no money.
You know what's trash? A discover
card. It's for your down years.
So when you,
if you're in,
you're broke years now you go ahead and
you get a discover card and you throw a
couple of grand on it and you'll pay it
off eventually and you don't have nice
teeth. You know what I would do
what? I blow the Wu Tang clan. Jesus.
What if they offered that we're going to
fix your teeth? Absolutely. All night.
That lady can give a Bj.
Huh? The head fits real nice.
Right in there. You're your best blowjob
years. Yeah. She knows how to do it right.
The price tag is on.
I said 40 you said 66 this was like
prices right here. Okay. Yup. Yup.
[inaudible] is terrible.
It kind of read the gums are look like
have periodontal it didn't find out.
Yeah, let's, let's see. But that
the gums are are, first of all,
they got a match and not everybody has
the same color gums I know. Or the teeth.
Terrible. You have to be shaped
to fit your teeth and your mouth.
That's why veneers are so expensive.
Cause somebody custom crafts them
to match your everything else.
Yeah. The length of the, the width,
the shape has to go with your,
what you have already.
Just one size fits all veneers.
Damn.
Catch your life.
The smile.
It was like a smile system here.
The million dollar smile. But that,
that's funny because I,
I just clicked on that
and it didn't even say,
um,
let's see.
I went to $1 million smile
and it was for a teeth.
Whitener it's like a different
by perfect smile veneers. Okay,
let me try it again. Million
dollar smile. Perfect.
Smile veneers.
Okay,
let's see.
Um, perfect smile. Okay. It's
called, it's perfect. Smile teeth.
Wow. Buy One, get one 1499
99,
1515 buy one get one.
Buy One get one. Only go. I just
pulled the same thing. Yeah.
Oh, Ooh. What was that fifth? It's our,
our nanny putting our kid down.
That's how she puts him down.
She just throws him in the crib.
No, she knocked over the desk.
[inaudible] I know that sounds very well.
You get two for 15
[inaudible] 15 so I went,
I was guessing 40 oh.
Oh she looks terrible.
She looks slutty.
Of course she does.
Do you think she became slightly
because her teeth, in other words,
did you overcompensate for how she
felt about this by being slutty?
Cause she has like a slutty slutty.
Right. There's no low lights.
When you bleach your hair blond,
you got to have low lights.
You can't just do one white.
He's a good friend. He's sweet.
He's like, I'll watch your house. I'll
make sure your mom gets home safe. Yeah.
Like I want, I like him. I like
her. I feel like she's like a,
like a working mom. This lady, she
works at the bank. Yeah. She's nice.
This one where I've got trust issues.
I don't like her at all. Yeah. Yeah,
I see there is that sled again.
She blondie,
she's doing like some real paid.
You know what that looks like? They
look like fake. Um, Halloween teeth,
like Dracula teeth do not wear
perfect smile when eating,
but yet they plug it that you wear it
on a date. Oh right. Multiple Times.
Even showed someone on a date.
Wait,
can you even sleep while wearing the
perfect to not wear it when sleeping.
You can't do shit with your perfect smile.
Can I wear it more than this
is the biggest red flag.
I mean it's obvious it's 15 bucks,
but they like weird on a date and
then I just want to just donate.
You're on a diet.
It's designed to be worn frequently.
Remember to take it out at night when,
when eating that of
where it all over again.
It's one size fits all for your mouth.
Can we order when?
Let's order it just to see what it's
like. Oh Man. I'm dying to see how,
let's order it and I'll try
it. Okay, well I don't know.
Maybe I should try it.
You want to try it cause I got real
veneers but they get stuck to those and
ripped off. That'd be bad as far. No,
I'm doing select one.
Okay. Not right now around. I know. I
want to make sure that I don't forget.
So I'm putting this thing in there. I'll
make a note of it. The perfect smile,
dude.
Guess what?
Shipping and handling is 1398 and the
the thing is 1499 that's bullshit.
There's, there's no reason it's $13
for shipping and handling says seven,
but I think it's because there's an
additional one in there. It goes up.
That's stupid. Yeah. We ship things from
stamps.com it doesn't cost that much,
you know?
But do you want to have nice teeth or not?
Sometimes you got to pay the price. All
right. I just started in the [inaudible].
You Ready? Yeah. Perfect.
Or can't talk.
Wearing perfect smile is a perfect smile.
Don't eat, don't sleep and don't try to
talk with your perfect smile day though.
I feel bad for these people,
man. Of course. Yeah. If you're,
if you're getting the perfect smile,
things have not gone well for you. Yeah,
you're me. You're making bad
decisions. Yeah, that's true.
And I'm telling you don't do it
and encourage this, but now I do.
Uh,
it's,
it's okay to spend the money man on
teeth. Yeah. It's a priority. Yeah.
You really got to, we've been saying
that on the show for years. Yeah.
I do it every 10 years. I rap and I
have to get two new front teeth. Yeah.
And we had a, it costs a fortune a
lot of that when you did it then.
And I still did it. Yeah. Cause it's
a priority. I know. And I'd actually,
I didn't even blink and you're like, I
got to get my teeth. And I was like, yeah,
of course. Of course. Of course.
You do. Some people let
it go. Let it go. Oh yeah.
Let's see.
Ready?
Hmm.
Stupid Bitch.
If the driver of this car had
kept his speed to a hundred k,
he is where he would have stopped if
he'd stopped here. His wife wouldn't
take the full impact of the
crash and die instantly.
If he'd stopped here.
The last thing Sally will ever hear
wouldn't be the sound of our own neck
breaking. All right. I gotta like Nikki.
Can we stop [inaudible] ribs
and her collarbone? As for Jim,
well, Jim could have avoided
broken bones and a broken heart,
but anyway, it's too late for all that
now because this isn't where it stops.
It's where it all day.
Okay.
Wow.
Ah,
Aussies that seem,
can we stop or we done?
This is terrible.
Okay.
Wow. All right. Okay. All right. Jeans.
Um,
anything else
we can't close on that. Let's see
what's up with pastor manning. Okay,
pastor meeting. Here we go.
I haven't seen him in awhile.
He's really, you know the pastor man,
and we played him before. He's, um,
what's wrong with you?
What's wrong with y'all?
Right.
That's pastor James David Madigan.
I'm the Lord's servant. I'm the
sodomites. Slay on the Solo. Satan,
the son of a sacco white trash.
If you thought that aids was bad,
you ain't seen nothing yet. You
ain't seen nothing yet. Yeah.
Well,
you ain't seen nothing my friend,
until you have a flame coming out of
your butthole and you live in as best as
diaper the baby. But to keep that flame
from burning a hole in your pants,
you ain't seen nothing yet.
I got a penis injected and the Butthole,
a penis injected in a
butthole of every Saturday.
Every Saturday night for a sodomite
has a penis injected in my butthole.
I got a burning man.
The only thing that's like out,
really outrageous cause this
guy's such a, uh, a hateful,
homophobic lunatic.
The only thing that always blows my mind
is that he has actual followers. Tons.
Yeah. I mean, I don't know about tons,
but he definitely has Brooklyn. Right?
Does he have, uh, uh, I think he's,
I don't know if it's Brooklyn. It's,
it's in New York for sure.
But he,
he has people that far,
like he is the lead pastor at a lot
of, you know, for a lot of people.
And it's, I dunno man.
It's a really, really,
really nuts that, that this is
their, this is the guy they look to,
to teach, you know, he's a
teacher essentially. Yup.
Shows you the impact, right?
Yeah. I mean this guy is
teaching people. Yeah.
Why don't we got a plane
coming out of my butt? Oh God.
I'm going to become a sodomized.
Got of cutting out of the butthole.
Jesus.
Come into my bud TD Jakes.
Creflo dollar Barack Hussein Obama.
The come into my bud.
You better go and pray to God and
ask God to come into, in my blood.
When that penis comes out the frame, we'll
start writing. Yeah. I'm not the worst,
but butthole.
Uh, yeah. I think maybe he's
in Harlem. Harlem, right?
There we go. That law organization. Yeah.
Healing word in my butt hole and
got the wide and mountain pothole.
Right now somebody's
on Harlem Nights.
Oh,
the faggots up him and mark borrowed.
Thank you. Going to be in the midst
of the swamps of South Carolina.
All of a sudden Harlem's going to
be lit up. What? Faggots. Okay.
And Mark.
Okay. Thank you for making me play
that pain. That's really cool.
Thank you for putting that on the
list. Really Neat. And that was a nice,
definitely funnier than the
horrifying PSA we just saw. Yeah.
And snakes and stuff.
Cut that together. Um,
very, very well done to I
to cut him together. Um,
all right. Genes. Um,
very fun episode again.
Every episode of your mom's house
is now available for download. Uh,
sorry.
Absolutely bombarded your feeds.
We did it with,
with good intentions in our hearts.
And my 2017 tore no teeth.
No entry will begin in January.
Tickets go on sale this Friday.
The 21st.
It's too bad you can't get sponsored by
the million dollar smile. Now. They won't.
Maybe I could. Maybe I
had a shot. Um, and uh,
I think that's, that's that. That's
it. Guys. Thank you for listening.
Thank you for watching us on Youtube and
we'll see you next week. Don't forget,
uh, Christians, uh,
Cincinnati and Indianapolis
tits starting Sunday.
Indianapolis had Sunday death.
That's why. That's right.
Are you saying that with your
million dollar smile in Indianapolis?
I'm fire the [inaudible].
You didn't want it was supposed to do. I
was supposed to get robbed. You're fine.
Arts can not in cake.
I won't say what tells the pain.
These are from Mickey Esposito.
Everybody's panties in a
wad. When I come up here,
she'll send them to her.
Okay. Now these here,
they can't even spit on my ankle.
Did you see me in a book?
What am I stupid?
I have,
I have
no idea. Who knows me? You
have no idea. Who knows me?
Women are stupid.
I have to
by half
and get what
you want to go
stupid.